c'est dans ce studio radio de
l'autoroute paris rhin rhône que l'
alerte est déclenchée quand une voiture
roule à contresens
les automobilistes entendent alors ce
message une pile à contresens la radio
107.7 diffuse alertes et les opérateurs
du poste de contrôle centrale met en
route la suite du processus pour éviter
le pire la première chose que nous
devons faire ce sont deux fermes et les
péages des autoroutes de la section le
contresens est signalé pour que les
personnes ne puisse pas rentrer sur
l'autoroute et rencontrer ce véhicule et
les panneaux comme on dit pmv sont
activés pour que l'information
contresens véhicule signalé soient
indiqués ce phénomène n'est pas si rare
400 véhicules roulant à contresens sont
signalés sur l'autoroute chaque année
ils ont provoqué la mort de 28 personnes
en 2016
mais comment un conducteur peut-il se
retrouver en sens inverse sur
l'autoroute
trois raisons principales sont évoqués
l'alcool les stupéfiants et l'âge avancé
du conducteur
dans tous les cas le contrevenant est
complètement désorienté il n'a pas
conscience du danger qu'ils encourent à
la prr la société chargée de
l'exploitation d'un réseau routier
les infrastructures sont étudiées pour
pallier ce phénomène déjà nos voix sont
séparés avec des balises au milieu pour
éviter que les personnes prennent
l'autoroute à contresens au niveau des
ronds points les rangs poisson construit
de telle sorte qu'il n'est pas possible
de prendre un contresens les barrières
des péages aussi ne permettent pas
d'être prise à contre sens puisqu'elles
sont en sens unique
un détecteur de contresens est
actuellement testé sur un site pilote
si le résultat est positif 21 sites où
l'on constate le plus ce fléau en seront
dotés